après la question du couvre-feu celle du
confinement voilà la nouvelle petite
musique qui tourne en boucle dans les jt
un essai de noël va-t-on pouvoir les
passer avec ses proches
est ce qu'on va vers des fêtes de fin
d'année qu'en finesse annulé noël une
expression choc qui fait de plus en plus
son chemin dans les débats si cette
question était d'abord inenvisageable il
ya quelques jours avec la montée des cas
et la menace d'une troisième vague
aujourd'hui l'idée semble bien là une
idée que christophe barbier avait
pourtant déjà évoqué en mars dernier sur
bfm tv ce qu'on peut faire c'est avoir
une volonté collective et poétique de
repousser noël et de dire noël ce sera
le 25 mars 2000 28 ans veut repousser
plutôt que d'annuler voilà l'idée qui
avait été aussi reprise non sans
moquerie par une médecin belge sur la
rtbf qui avait proposé quant à elle de
reporter noël à l'été éventuellement
reporter des fêtes de fin d'année ou de
noël en juillet-août quand il fait beau
et faire une grande fête dans votre
jardin
de son côté le ministre de la santé
olivier ferrand se veut pour le moment
plus optimistes et espèrent un
déconfinement avant les fêtes mais étant
donné l'aggravation de la situation ces
dernières heures
rien n'est moins sûr je ne fais pas de
pronostics vous ne verrez jamais faire
des pronostics ce n'est pas d'hier que
cet effectif il fallait que je suis
prudent alors faut-il annuler noël
moi déjà j'ai une grande question posée
téléspectateurs cette histoire de dire
on va faire noël en mars pour moi c'est
dit c'est ridicule
christophe barbier sur bfm il a dit
christophe il a dit faudrait faire une
grande fête voilà par exemple en mars si
tropiques c'est noël non mais oui mais
pour moi circulent plus grave du monde
mais déjà c'est improbable de dire on va
faire ça en mars mais qui va faire ça en
mars mais non mais qu en juillet mais
non moi je dis oui et je m'oublie par
ces cas là c'est clair non mais tu me
dis mais non mais en fait non moi je
mets oui parce que c'est pas bon je sais
que c'est important c'est très important
mais je pense pas que ce soit un noël
qui va tous nous je pense que c'est plus
important de respecter les règles et de
faire en sorte qu'ils aient moins de
mahler possible plutôt que je sais que
ça va faire beaucoup de malheurs mais
c'est bien trop grave comme situation
chez du werder il faut pour moi nulle et
noël ça peut pas être un noël de sa peut
pas être en aucun cas un noël de
réunions familiales avec plusieurs
générations sinon c'est une troisième
vague assuré c'est là dessus que planche
le gouvernement
moi je pense qu'on va nous demander
effectivement de ne pas circuler à noël
vous pensez que noël c'est oui ça va
être un noël a au téléphone ou par
application où chacun de son côté
dr il s'est peut être nicolas pernikoff
merci à jour aujourd'hui de pleurer
quand j'entends c'est une catastrophe
sociale si on annule nouvel appareil
vers noël en mars est ridicule essayé de
réserver si on fait noël en mer et
pourquoi pas pas conduit hier samedi au
mois d'août ans non mais c'est ça
n'importe quoi oui mamie moi je trouve
parce que nous on dit pour nous on peut
effectivement essayé d'amener sur moi je
suive s'arroger tous ceux qui jouent le
maintien de noël et l'aménager oui mais
moi je connais plusieurs personnes en
ehpad qui ne rêve que d'une seule ment
c'est que vous en connaissez beaucoup
pour exactement ses pouvoirs au moins un
soir voir leur fils ou leur fille a bien
sûr qu'ils n'auront peut-être pas de
noël
l'année prochaine je suis désolé mais
moi je connais des gens qui disent on va
se laisser mourir de tristesse est la
raison machir ils se sont résignés les
français le le papa de kenny d'abord
sonné le papa rené développer mon nom
est vraiment voilà je trouve ça
scandaleux si on irait cud autour de ce
qui dit oui aux dieux qui n'ont pas
d'âme pas dépasser vrai moi même mes
petites
ils sont contre le report de loin et
vite moody a failli zone 30 ans
baptisera vertain quand même 17 heures
et 14 heures et puis voilà sur l'humain
qu'à noël soit tu ne semble pas qu il y
en a beaucoup
non rassure le dire à noël il y avait
beaucoup ils se réunissent maintenant et
nous ce sera un jour dans l'année
bien sûr alors comment ne tombe pas
déconner rsa et dessine
bah oui mais en fait on n'est pas ça
près on a déjà passé 2 confinement des
fois sinon qu'en fait on on préfère que
maintenant bon voilà on fait pas de noël
et qu'après ce soit derrière nous pour
de vrai parce que quand on parle de 3e
bat vraiment peur quoi maturité je pense
que les gens devraient se voir sur toute
la semaine de noël et se voit alors du
gouverneur il ya peu plus attisé qui
veut parler mais comment tu comprends
bien classés on a des mouvements de
populations encore que tout le monde ce
n'est pas ça met un drame au père noël
de francs avec moins de monde mais me
direz que c'est de déplacer en face il y
avait au champ de mars
vieux personnes mais tous ces petits
bijoux de personnes qui seront c'est
tout c'est pas une ou deux mois j'aurais
alors j'aurais dit que j'avais posé une
question e s que pour noël ça sent le
sapin de rené la ramasse il est la
ramasse les clusters c'est pas forcément
rassemblement des cédants le nettoyer à
mille éclats celui là il n'est plus
adéquat y est abbas et professeurs non
mais on va dire qu'elle est femme au coq
sert non dits et les femmes au foyer
c'est plus roanne qui comblera les
savait que ça existe pas lancé dans le
cercle familial arica que les maladies
se transmettent plus il faut mieux faire
décaler noël que de faire un noël
parfait si les mâconnais
s'il vous plaît étalés sur la semaine de
noël je pense même arrêté d'étaler vous
croisez des oiseaux les français se sont
résignés il ya un sondage qui a été
effectué pour 53% des sondés il ne
souhaite pas fêter noël
donc ça y est c'est fait c'est acté et
pourquoi ils protègent leur famille aux
parents imaginez on est à table en voir
que c'est les gens qui ont décidé c'est
le gouvernement c'est pas nous non mais
là un sondage
mais ici au bénin le sondage il suit il
a sûrement un français sur deux jours en
suisse est par contre à partir du 20
novembre on pourra acheter des sapins de
noël
hubert j'aimerais avoir l'avis de bouder
qui fêtent noël est aussi un héros et
bout des héros
oui je suis d'accord avec ce que l'on
appelle ici d'accord excuse un enfant
dans sa lutte un non mais je suis
d'accord aussi avec ce que vous dites
mais pour les personnes qui sont dans
les ehpad et tout mais oui c'est très
compliqué à vivre que je te jure
mais voilà il faudrait peut-être trouvé
un entre deux alors ici loin pour
vraiment faire un nom à la mignon le
faire midi pour les personnes nous
regardent sachez qu'on aura toutes les
réponses dans un instant puisque le père
noël sera avec nous
ferrer projet de moi lui dire moi là je
sens mais c'est possible serait avec
nous aujourd'hui ou demain mais le père
noël on est en contact avec lui il
risquerait de donner toutes les réponses
prochainement voilà mon angoisse en tout
cas pas des séries nous appelle de
celui-ci
comme ni bouder 4 je te dis c'est une
boutade
on le fait à midi ils se regardent le
gouvernement il nous fait le couvre feu
de 22 à 20 heures si on était sûrs que
le vide
il est la nuit alors le fait de vous
comment son étole qu'ils ont l'air
chiant tout net c'est pas bête il est
temps de passer à d'autres laisse croire
il se voit ce qu'on pense les
téléspectateurs oui à 29% non à 61,67
vous avez sorti votre sondage mais ça ça
doit être un de sondages m radio merci